WALL LOST IMCDONAGH TOOK IT OFF.
SA LINE AS TAMPA
TRIES TO COUNTER QUICKLY.
ON UP HIGH BY RYAN ST A 12-GAME
DROUGHT WITHOUT A GOAL IN GAME 2
-- CHYTIL WI
RANGERS.
AGEL.
SHOT UP HIGH,
MCDONAGH TAKES A SHOT.
BLOCKED.
HERE IS KUCHEROV, DECIDED TO
THROW IT OUT THE SZIBANEJAD CO'.
TROUBA, TOP OF THE CIRCLE, OFF
THEBREAKAWAY, CHOPPED BY SHESTEN
-- STOPPED IT.
HE TAKES A LONG PASS, BEAUTY FOR
RYAN MCDONAGH BEHINDKUCHEROV, AT
OPPORTUNITIES.
SILEVSKIY ON
BOUDREAU.
FROM POINT PLAYING RANGE --
POINT-BLANK RANGE AND SLOT,
BUMPING IT OFF FORAGEL.
OUTPUCK, AND ON HIS BACK,
DUMPS Y.
THE COMMITMENT WITH GAUDREAU
GAUDREAU ALL ALONE.
AT TO
PERRY.
THE ARWER PLAY GOAL!
NICO ZIBANEJAD MAKES 19 GOALS OE
BLOCKER SIDE.
CHRIS KREIDER OUT IN FRONT.
ANOTHER POWER PLAY GOAL FOR NEW
YORK.
AND ATERRIFIC SAVES BY VASILEVS.
WITH KREIDER INSIDE OF
THE
PERIOD.
KUCHEROV, WHO WASWE ARE UNDERWA.
VASILEVSKIY NOTSTAMKOS A ROCKET.
BAY.
BETWEEN THE POST AND THE GLOVE.